i think the way forward for i think the
waveform for the country as a whole is
to continue with the path that we're on
uh we'll keep everything under review of
course we keep all measures under review
but the the mixture of
of things that we're doing at the moment
is i think the right one so number one
continue with with plan b make sure that
people take it seriously do what we can
to stop the the spread use the plan b
measures work from home if you can wear
a mask on public transport
be sensible about take a test before
going out to meet people you don't
normally meet
think about the the the requirements
under plan b but also get the the
booster and i think that's the
difference between the uk and
so much of the rest of of europe and
perhaps the rest of the world we have a
very very high level of vaccination now
and we need to continue very fast to
build up those defenses and those uh
that protection in the population about
30 almost 34 million people 33.9 million
people across the uk have had a booster
amongst the the 70
to 75 group uh you're looking at over 90
percent of people have had it huge
numbers uh i think 76 percent of adults
76 about so everybody who's thinking
about it
get a boost and you're you're joining
the vast majority i think we've got to
recognize that the
the pressure on our nhs on our hospitals
is going to be uh considerable in the
course the next couple of weeks and
maybe more because there's no question
omicron continues to to surge through
the country
a third jab really does make a big big
difference uh there are two million
slots just this week to get your booster
so get boosted now it can make all the
difference in the world the majority of
people who are in icu sadly have not
been
vaccinated and certainly the vast
majority about 90 have not been boosted
we'll continue to look at the
infectivity periods but the key thing is
we don't want to be
releasing people back into the workplace
when they're still infectious and the
risk is you'd increase the numbers of
people going back into the workplace who
are infectious by a factor of three so
you might perversely have a negative
effect on on the workforce if you saw me
so that's the that's the argument we're
looking at